entourée de forêts en plein coeur des
yvelines la pépinière dessert des
princesses à saint germain en laye a en
apparence tout d'une pépinière classique
on peut y acheter des fleurs des arbres
des légumes et des conserves mais c'est
pourtant la seule ville de france à
avoir quatre pôles de production le
verger le maraîchage la floriculture et
la pépinière on a des méthodes de
gestion qui sont un petit peu que pas
conventionnel on va dire et qui
s'intègre dans dans l'actualité c'est à
dire l'intégration de la biodiversité
dans nos pratiques la pépinière plus axé
sur la production travaille en étroite
collaboration avec la société halte et
corporacion géré par adrien le tallec
plus spécialisés sur la
commercialisation un partenariat gagnant
gagnant qui permet à adrien le tallec
d'accueillir au sein de la pépinière des
élèves en stage ou en formation des
personnes en reconversion ou encore des
travailleurs handicapés ce qu'on va
mettre en avant est avant tout c'est la
formation ces deux
de pouvoir
valoriser le métier et donner envie aux
jeunes et aux moins jeunes de découvrir
le métier alors lui si on va reprendre
le chiffrage sur lequel on était on peut
aller sur du ceap et du bac pro
donc plus des postes d'ouvriers
jusqu'à ensuite des formations plus
diplômante plus certifiante comme lucie
où là on est sur une formation assistant
métreur moment j'étais dans la
conception j'ai fait une formation
collaborateurs concepteur paysagiste que
dans l'établissement cfa et du coup là
mon intérêt c'était de voir le chiffrage
est vraiment le mettrais et le terrain
comme je n'ai pas encore fait de terrain
jusque là également associé au lycée
horticole et agricole de saint germain
en laye la pépinière s'articule autour
de deux maîtres mots production et
pédagogie elle accueille des élèves du
lycée en formation durant leurs cours
pratiques le but c'est de leur faire
acquérir des compétences et des
capacités pour qu'ils puissent gérer par
eux mêmes leurs chantiers et que ça
puisse leur servir dans leur vie
professionnelle future je rentrais
défaire un rempotage et un rempotage
c'est remettre de la plainte dans une
nouvelle peau j'ai beaucoup appris et
dans tous les quatre domaines parce que
ici ils font tous les quatre dans mail
des valeurs de transmission qui sont
chers à la pépinière comme adrien le
tallec et qui permettent chaque année à
des dizaines d'élèves de trouver leur
vocation